We've reached the end to another lesson and
we learned a lot of important concepts that we're
going to summarize into five main points. Point one our
genome's are largely made up of non-coding sequences which
play a major role in influencing the transcription of
coding regions. Point two. All coding regions have a
non-coding sequence called a promoter that's typically located in
front of the transcription initiation site and is essential
for transcription to occur. Point three:
The consensus TATA sequence, or TATA-box, is
common to promoters of many genes and is essential for their transcription to
occur. Point 4. Activators and repressors
are transcription factors, or proteins that combine
enhancers and silencers that regulate gene expression,
typically through combinatorial regulation. And point 5.
All humans have two copies of non-coding alleles,
just as they have two copies of coding alleles.